on the mound for the red sox making his
warm-up tosses
is the veteran right-hander garrett
richards he'll turn 33
this friday
two-ball two-strike pitch coming from
richards
here it is and he swings it hits it
weakly on a soft top to the right of the
mound grabbed by richards on the second
hop flips the first for the out there
retires the side and 37 year old charlie
morton certainly a big game pitcher
ready to deliver here orton at a slow
start pitching better of late two and
two with a 4-6-0 era his first year with
the braves the first pitch is swung on a
broken bat one hopper goes through in
the left center of base
hit they have the shift on but
he got it to the
left of the shortstop one-two pitch
line drive oh it gets right through all
these
runners are gonna try and move up and
everybody's going to be safe on that
line shot
and the bases are loaded with nobody out
here in the first inning that was a
missile i mean he put his glove down
i'll be saying and it didn't get him
going his glove
swaying and a miss would he need that
everything hard and then he pulls the
string for out number one
the two two
you hit him he gets hits with a
curveball the ball bounces halfway to
third base
tk picks it up in fact as he trots home
one nothing red sox
line to short double play at second and
charlie morton needed that a hit batsman
costs him a run it could have been a
whole lot worse and the braves are up in
the second
century swung on and missed for strike
three
and riley who's been as hot as a
firecracker goes down swinging
shot toward the wall racing back verdugo
catches the 10.
pablo will have himself a long single
off the wall in the first hit off of
garrett richards tonight for atlanta the
braves have two on and one out
another bullet hit towards center
santana back that one's off the base of
the wall streaking around third as
contreras he is going to score standing
up ball gets away in the middle of the
diamond and atlanta's tied the game on a
bullet by ozuna to straight away center
it's 1-1 and the braves are rolling here
in the third inning
a shot into the
shallow right field portion of the field
and ozuna's tagged out going second to
third and he's hurting
oh did he mess up a finger
he might have dislocated a finger oh
zuna diving into the third base bag i
think he dislocated a finger
the braves are going to get a run
and ozuna diving into third base has
injured his hand
so walby's gets the ball to the right
side of the infield he will reach on the
fielder's choice
oh man fingertips right across the shoes
and ozuna's
gunned down at third base
and evers knew he saw it immediately
so fielder's choice rbi for all these
freeman scores ozuna is out four to five
o2 count
and a swing of miss there's charlie
morton curveball high fastball jd
martinez is strikeout victim number
three
the red sox missed their chances
leaves you wondering about the rest of
the night
that's going to be ripped into left
that's down for a hit over to cut it
adrianza it'll be a long single for
xander with two down
as the starters get settled that'll make
the pen settle and it has worked out
that way as charlie is settling in he
preserves the lead and the braves bats
go back to work in the fourth with a 2-1
lead
and is chopped up the middle he's three
for three
well that'll make those fans just real
happy keep keep it going pablo
and the o2 from garrett
caught on and missed he struck him out
two gone
hirokazu sawamura
on in relief of garrett richards who
departs after five and two thirds
and the two base runners belong to him
sandoval
and contreras
and now he has to deal sarmura does with
the top of the order and acuna junior
they've left three on base since and
have two on here
toward left field into the corner of
base here that's going to score one
sandoval chugs around he's going to
score
and atlanta gets a big two out hit from
acuna to extend the lead
that run belongs to garrett richards
so this will be an intentional pass to
load him up got to one and one on
freeman and passed on him so adrianza
will climb in he's over one he's
grounded to second first second and
third two down and the two two on the
way
and in there to strike him out went to
the fastball to get him
as charlie morton goes to work in the
seventh inning swaying and a miss he's
still throwing awfully hard his 90th
pitch at 96 miles an hour that's eight
strikeouts
one shy of his season high with the
braves and if they keep swinging at
pitches like that he's not going to have
any trouble that ties his season high
he's retired the last 12 red sox in
order nine strikeouts and two away
the 2-2
broken bat into left but caught by
adrianza and charlie morton with seven
brilliant innings in boston has staked
the braves to a 3-1 lead
and his spot of banning order is next as
freddie shoots one the other way that's
freddie freeman like that'll bang around
to the corner of the 310 mark and
freddie freeman has a two-hit game
that's his fifth double
stays the same in this one too then
sox would still be a half game back
going into tomorrow and the yankees
would be one out all behind tampa bay
but the red sox still have an
opportunity in this one and
vasquez taking a knock here that one bit
him a little bit huh
christian trying to walk it off
change up
down
oh
at least he had a little bit of padding
there but i don't know how much that
helped
some bite more than others i guess you
know
what a job yeah you could have it
they start
pushing on between that and home run uh
home plate up highest
what a beating
plenty of those for jason vernon second
his day
knows exactly how that feels
so christian vasquez to hang in
and the braves run out away
the pitch to vasquez
hay struck him out and will smith has
his eighth save charlie morton has his
96th career win he was masterful at
fenway park again tonight jeff and
despite some early traffic on the base
pass
charlie morton rolled he retired the
last 13 men he faced and the braves road
trips off to a great start